on some savait qu'à arroser roja ce
alonso juriste franco-espagnole bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous re 0 grâce alonso
l'espagne qui est désormais le pays le
plus touché de l'europe après l'italie
comment vous l'expliquez c'est difficile
à expliquer je crois que même les les
spécialistes les épidémiologistes et les
médecins ont du mal à expliquer la
vitesse à laquelle les pays les uns
derrière les autres ont été contaminés
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que les
chiffres évoluent très vite vous aviez
parlé tout à l'heure d'un nombre d'un
nombre de décès un peu inférieur à 800
on aider on a déjà dépassé
malheureusement les 803 décès c'est des
chiffres que j'ai moins relevé à 18
heures il ya dix sept mille trois cents
ans malade dans toute l'espagne est avec
une grande concentration de malades dont
les régions de madrid de catalogne et du
et du pays basque alors la vitesse à
laquelle se propage le virus
je crois que cette question elle se pose
un peu à tous les pays dans des pays
comme comme les pays latins la france
l'espagne et l'italie
c'est vrai que je pense que le il faut
expliquer aussi que les gens sortent
beaucoup les gens j'allais dire son sont
toujours en contact les uns avec les
autres games une
une forme de vie qui plus chaleureuses
peut-être que dans les pays du nord de
l'europe peut-être ça peut expliquer
aussi la rapidité de la contamination
mais surtout on est face à quelque chose
qu'on n'a jamais vus auparavant
on n'a jamais été confrontée à une crise
sanitaire de cette ampleur avec une
maladie donc ce coronavirus pour lequel
pour l'instant il n'y a toujours pas de
vaccin
toujours pas de traitement directement
efficace et ça pose énormément de
problèmes
l'espagne prend comme la france et
l'italie
les mêmes mesures aujourd'hui le
gouvernement a déclaré
l'état d'alarmé en espagne sur tout le
territoire espagnol avec maintenant une
gestion beaucoup plus centralisée des
choses c'est à dire une prise en main
des choses par le gouvernement central
ce qui est une nouveauté dans un pays
aussi décentraliser que l'espagne ce qui
n'est pas parfois sans friction
notamment avec le problème éternel des
ddd certains martyrs dépend dentiste
catalans qui cherchent encore à voir
derrière cette centralisation dictée par
la nécessité
une sorte de manoeuvre politique qui
n'existe par il ya largement une
consensus une quasi unanimité des forces
politiques pour soutenir le gouvernement
en espagne comme dans les autres pays et
je crois que c'est une bonne chose pour
l'instant il faut renforcer cette unité
le combat se mène avec tout le monde
avec tous les citoyens les citoyens en
restant chez eux le personnel sanitaire
on l'a vu ton de tous les personnels qui
sont nécessaires pour faire fonctionner
le pays dans ses fonctions basiques la
distribution des aliments l'alimentation
qui est nécessaire pour tous les
habitants espagnols comme ça l'est aussi
en france et aussi le bon
approvisionnement en médicaments et en
matériel sanitaire des pharmacies et
surtout des hôpitaux bien sûr vous
parliez de cette prise en charge du
gouvernement central 1 de cette crise
est ce que les mesures ont été prises
peut-être un peu tard en espagne
également à l'instar certainement de de
tous les pays d'europe
si je pense que c'est toujours facile de
juger des actions d'un gouvernement
comme ça après coup
quand on est dans le feu de l'action et
sur le moment c'est très compliqué comme
on dira si tel ou tel pays a pris des
mesures en avance ou en retard c'est moi
je dis que je dirais que c'est
extrêmement difficile à analyser
pourquoi parce que c'est ce virus est
parti d'un pays comme la chine dont on
ne peut pas dire que l'information et
transparentes
on a vu également que
il ya eu par exemple un pays qui a été
relativement épargné par les contagions
c est un pays comme la russie où parfois
on peut aussi douter de la sincérité de
l'information des médias officiels donc
c'est très difficile d'analyser dans ces
conditions là si tel ou tel gouvernement
a pris à temps où on n'a pas pris à
temps les mesures nécessaires c'est un
dilemme je crois que pour tous les
gouvernements en europe comme ailleurs
il fallait faire un choix entre
paralyser l'économie comme on le fait
aujourd'hui avec cette obligation le
confinement en france en espagne en
italie et bientôt dans d'autres pays si
il faut paralyser l'économie pour
accorder au secteur sanitaire aux
médecins aux hôpitaux le temps de
s'organiser face à l'avalanche des
nouveaux malades
donc c'est extrêmement difficile à quel
moment on prend une décision de
confinement qui va provoquer des
concessionnaires et des conséquences
économiques bien sûr très importante
dans tous les pays européens
il ya quel moment on les prend quel
monde doit les prendre c'est très
difficile de juger l'opportunité et la
sagesse d'un gouvernement dans une
situation que personne n'avait prévu qui
est tout à fait nouvelle et inédite et
qui a pris des dimensions mondiales en
quelques semaines ce qui ne s'était
quasiment jamais vu dans l'histoire
jusqu'à maintenant c'est aussi là d un
des effets de ce qu'on appelle la
globalisation la mondialisation les gens
voyagent beaucoup plus qu'avant les
citoyens d'un pays vont beaucoup plus
facilement à l'autre bout de la planète
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus facilement qui
a dix ou vingt ans donc tout ça ce sont
des facteurs de risques naturels de
contamination qu'on avait peut-être pas
il ya 30 ou 40 ans l'impact de cette
maladie il beaucoup plus est d'autant
plus grand aujourd'hui que les moyens de
communication les transports aériens les
transports terrestres aussi sont
beaucoup plus rapides aujourd'hui qu'il
ya 20 ou 30 ans je pense que c'est ça
qui explique aussi la rapidité de la
contagion et surtout est surtout là je
pense que le plus important ce que pose
comme question cette cette crise
sanitaire c'est de savoir si
nous avons tout fait dans les pays
européens pour soutenir le secteur de la
santé les médecins les hôpitaux il ya
beaucoup de mouvements sociaux dans les
hôpitaux français depuis deux 2 2 3 ans
il y en a eu aussi en espagne on a dans
certaines régions voulu absolument
privatiser une grande partie du secteur
de santé
peut-être qu'il se proposait de la
question savoir quel choix on doit faire
dans un pays moderne sur le secteur de
la santé pour être capable de faire face
à des crises comme ça un jour on voit
que dans tous les pays où manquent des
masques de protection il manque du
matériel de base y compris pour les
médecins c'est quelque chose qu'on
n'aurait jamais imaginé il ya seulement
quelques semaines
merci beaucoup à 0 ravalant d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rtl